eu tinha 13 anos eu jogava no infantil
da seleção da minha cidade estava no
vestiário ouvindo treinador a preleção
dele antes do jogo e ele nos dizia né
que naquele jogo naquele torneio
especial não teria cartão vermelho só
teria cartão amarelo tomado cartão
amarelo estava expulso de campo
a mensagem educativa era clara não tomem
cartão eu achei até coerente essa
preocupação excessiva dele porque
naquela época nas categorias de base e
as regras mudaram assim constantemente
né e por ser uma nova norma educativa
fomos para o jogo lá pro meio do
primeiro tempo
eu já tinha tomado algumas botinadas né
eu tomei uma entrada dura enquanto é só
uma entrada dura você levanta tomar
satisfação e oab estava do meu lado eu
olhei para ele e falei escuta só não vai
dar cartão não falou se em voo
esse aqui é só pra você e deus e eu
falei puxa vida foi expulso no primeiro
tempo né
que coisa triste né e aquela raiva
começou a subir e eu mandei ele apitar
jogo de botão
mas eu devo ter falado mais alguma coisa
que eu juro que eu não me lembro
e aí ele tirou do bolso vermelho
eu olhei pra ele eu falei só tem um
cartão vermelho e acho que ele ficou com
pena de mim né
e eu olhava pro meu treinador já
circulando maluco ali brava comigo né
mas acho que uma luz maior veio abaixo a
cabeça
o vestiário refletindo no que eu tinha
feito mas principalmente refletindo no
meu treinador tinha feito e acho que
desde então eu fui um cara muito mais
crítico em analisar de que forma os
treinadores transmitiam o conhecimento
para seus atletas dentro e fora de campo
eu começo com essa história mas a minha
relação no futebol
ela começa bem antes ela começa de uma
forma como aquela grande maioria de
jogadores de futebol é também começou
nos campinhos de futebol
as ruas de terra aliás essa é a foto do
meu campinho tá onde eu morava em três
campanhas num raio de 1 quilômetro mais
ou menos e se ficava 100 metros da minha
escola e ao lado da casa da minha avó
então o pessoal falava que esse era o
meu campinho aliás aquele aquele jovem
ali no gol é meu irmão e durante décadas
essa foi à escola do futebol brasileiro
esse ambiente natural espontâneo de
aprender futebol né da prática intensa
nos campinhos nas ruas de terra qualquer
lugar você jogava futebol nas praias
o tempo passou no lugar dos campinhos
surgiram os prédios no lugar das ruas de
terra foram asfaltadas e aquelas
práticas espontâneas viraram as
escolinhas de futebol e nas escolinhas
de futebol você também aprende a ver
futebol mas aprendi o futebol de um
jeito um pouco mais diferente
imagine uma criança que estuda de
segunda a sexta na escola normal
tradicional que faz também o inglês faz
um violão uma bateria e fica esperando o
dia do futebol chegar naquele dia tão
especial aquele dia mágico
ela vai para a aula de futebol aí ela
vai além do futebol
ela entra na fila pra chutar ela espera
a vez dela e ela espera a vez dela e
chuta e volta para trás da fila e aí ele
não pode desafiar e nem provocar o
amiguinho que está na outra fila porque
o professor fala e escuta aqui você vai
aprender futebol se não vai brincar
nessa veio pra aprender futebol então
virou o pé pra passar passa assim a
marca daquela forma
dribla assim tá e aquele menino no final
da aula acontece também outro fator
interessante no trajeto da escolinha
para a casa dele geralmente com os pais
não é com o pai aliás o pai durante todo
o trajeto questiona o filho porque ele
não fez aquele gol que estava sozinho
porque ele não marcou nem aquele menino
que entrou porque ele perdeu aquela
menina naquele jogo né
não é à toa que essa criança quando foi
realizar uma pesquisa recente com uma
centena de
crianças que jogavam em escolinhas de
futebol e à parte porque elas acham mais
chata justamente é a volta para casa com
os pais né
por sua vez o que eles gostam
tremendamente um dos pontos altos dessa
pesquisa é a volta com os avós que ao
contrário dos pais
ele só elogiam e falou quanto gostam de
ver seus netos jogarem então vejam a
transformação daquela prática espontânea
é natural né pra uma prática mais
regulada mecanizada ela vem provocando
mudanças significativas no perfil do
jogador de futebol brasileiro o perfil
do jogador atual e futuro quando a gente
privilegia o ensino fragmentado do
fundamento técnico o chute
o drible o controle de bola a gente vai
se distanciando dos aspectos mais
criativos mais lúdicos mais intuitivos e
coletivos que a essência do próximo do
próprio jogo
o professor alcides scaglia doutor
alcides scaglia um dos grandes pedagogos
do esporte brasileiro
na sua tese de mestrado ele fez uma
investigação entrevistou uma série de
jogadores
esses craques que tinham escolinhas de
futebol ele fez duas perguntas pra esses
ex craques como é que você aprendeu a
jogar futebol
a grande maioria era é bem interessante
isso é porque a grande maioria sentava
encostava abre um sorriso falar puxa eu
descia do meu prédio com a bola eu já ia
driblando a guia eu dava uma meia lua na
árvore
eu chegava no campinho sabe tinha um
campinho que era um gol era a trave ea
outra na parede e aí eu lembro bem que
eu desenvolvi a habilidade de bater com
a esquerda e bateu com a direita a
chegar a 123 a gente brincava de
rebatida
depois a gente fazia bobinho e depois a
gente fazia a mãe da rua e ali eu
aprendi a controlar a bola em alta
velocidade e aí a segunda pergunta como
é que você ensina futebol dos seus
alunos
era muito interessante a grande maioria
deles também mudava o tom da voz fechava
o semblante e praticamente miniaturizar
vá o que eles aprenderam enquanto
profissionais traziam esse treino
monótono repetitivo mecânico para a vida
daquelas crianças
se a gente não entendeu o perfil da
criança de hoje
como é que a gente vai entender que tipo
de ambiente vai provocar vai estimular
melhor essa criança que mudou demais o
perfil da criança de hoje aquela criança
do meu tempo né
no meu tempo tinha a bola a bola a bola
ea bicicleta mas é optar pela bola hoje
o acesso das crianças a uma infinidade
de aparelhos de outras formas de
concorrência com o futebol o ipad o
iphone o videogame o minecraft whatsapp
o shopping né
então não é à toa não sei se vocês sabem
que nos últimos quatro anos diminuiu em
25%
aquelas pessoas interesse das pessoas
pelo futebol e essas mesmas pessoas hoje
em 10 25% não torcem pra time algum nem
para a seleção brasileira
outra coisa todo mundo diz que o
brasileiro nasce com a bola nos pés que
a gente é uma grande fábrica de talentos
na verdade agora pouca gente sabe que a
cada 3 mil crianças que tenta uma
oportunidade no clube só uma vai
conseguir pois é uma fábrica que gera
muito mais frustrações do que talento
em números absolutos a cada 300 mil
crianças e jovens que querem tem o sonho
de serem jogadores de futebol sem só vão
conseguir estão distribuídos dessa forma
7015 estão desempregados 70 vão ganhar
até cinco salários
até 20 salários e só cinco daqueles 300
mil vão ganhar aqueles salários que que
muitos consideram milionários
então o que fazer com essa grande massa
que fica pelo caminho para que a gente
não pode é não deve se preocupar de de
forma estratégica é porque o ápice dessa
pirâmide nunca vai ser totalmente
desenvolvido se a gente não pensar o que
fazer com a base dessa pirâmide
hoje alguns países isto estudam
compreende exploram o futebol com muito
mais propriedade do que a gente então na
nossa frente não só no ranking da fifa
mas no ranking de desenvolvimento humano
e da educação
na verdade a alemanha alemanha além da
gente toma uma goleada dentro de campo
foi um fez com um futebol muito né os o
futebol em toda a sua potencialidade
ao gerar carisma para o nosso povo né
estima respeito esse é um grande exemplo
para a gente se inspirar e hoje os
europeus conseguem fazer em vidro o que
nós não conseguimos mais fazerem natura
isso em relação a criar ambientes
estimulantes para o ensino do bom
futebol
eles praticamente depuração o que era
melhor daquela prática natural e
trofense passaram por um laboratório
elevaram hoje para o ensino do futebol
que lá acontece nas escolas públicas
antes de passar pelas escolinhas e para
os clubes
e tem outra coisa
o senso comum diz que o futebol a
educação é cultura é saúde e cidadania
você concorda com isso essa é uma grande
mentira gente
o futebol é que você faz dele aliás
quando a gente vai no estádio a gente vê
tudo o contrário
a gente vê violência a gente vê falta de
educação a gente vê falta de cidadania
na verdade o futebol
tem tudo de bom e tem tudo de ruim ele
né gente olha para um jogo que a gente
vê a coragem mas também vê a covardia
a gente vê o amor mas a gente vem
diferença
a gente vê a solidariedade ea gente vê o
smo a ousadia a cautela
a razão ea emoção a sanidade ea loucura
tá tudo lá né outro grande pensador do
nosso esporte professor joão batista
freire nos lembra o seguinte os
treinadores e professores que ensinam
futebol eles podem escolher se eles
potencializam os vícios ou as virtudes
será que aqui no brasil a gente vai ter
orgulho do futebol
só quando a gente ganha uma copa vai ser
tão mesquinho esse ponto de nos sentimos
orgulhosos com o que a gente faz com o
futebol e pelo futebol só levantando
mais um caneco
será que não seria interessante a gente
olhar para o poder do futebol como
instrumento de educação para educar para
estimular crianças pela escola e hoje é
cada vez maior o índice de crianças que
não gostam da escola
o futebol tem tudo nele não tem na
economia falar matemática física química
história geografia
será que um professor não pode pegar o
interesse da criança pelo real madrid eo
barcelona por exemplo e contar a guerra
civil espanhola
não tenho dúvida que ele vai fixar a
isso de uma maneira muito maior do que
aquela forma como tradicionalmente a
gente aprende classe de aula
será que ele não pode potencializar o
reforço dos capitais do nosso país a
partir dos nossos clubes que não pode
demonstrar por exemplo as formas
geométricas através das marcações do
campo né
os ângulos da física as reações químicas
a partir de uma própria partida de
futebol e principalmente gente
principalmente a partir do ensino do
próprio jogo dos fundamentos a técnica
tática inteligência coletiva de jogo que
a gente possa transmitir valores de uma
pessoa de bem
flores fundamentais é como solidariedade
como liderança autonomia respeito ao
adversário respeito ao seu companheiro
enfim isso é o que mais nos moveu para
desenvolver um projeto que a gente tem
muito orgulho na universidade do futebol
o projeto chamado de o cara pelo futebol
meu time nota 10 em parceria com o
unicef e com apoiado pela fundação
barcelona na verdade é um curso online
gratuito com conteúdo muito relevante
que vai ser orientado para treinadores
professores treinadores de escolinha e
tem com alguns objetivos entre eles
ensinar bem o futebol e ensinar mais do
que futebol
além de reforçar o direito à criança
adolescente pelo esporte e os riscos e
oportunidades em naquela em aquela
criança que quer se tornar um jogador de
futebol e esse projeto também desperta
para uma realidade que a gente vive aqui
não basta só saber de futebol
nós temos que entender estudar o futebol
com fins educativos com as práticas com
fins educativos para que a gente possa
mudar uma cultura vigente
aqui o futebol é admirado por milhões
praticado por muitos mas infelizmente
ainda estudado por poucos vou terminar
minha fala uma frase e uma foto que o
edge com muito carinho com o sócrates
que ele dizia
com a bola no pé a gente muda um país e
eu peço licença para alterar essa faça
essa frase pra dizer com a bola no pé e
gente que quer o bem do futebol
brasileiro a gente muda um país obrigado